manifestants arrêtés véhicules remorqués
la police canadienne a délogés dimanche
les derniers participants du convoi de
la liberté rassemblés sur le pont
ambassador
l'opération a débuté samedi matin pour
libérer sept axes transfrontaliers
névralgique entre le canada et les états
unis bloqué depuis près d'une semaine au
total une trentaine de manifestants ont
été arrêtés
nous avons pu évacuer la majorité des
manifestants dans la zone en nous
concentrant évidemment ici sur church
road avec nos agences et quand je dis no
c'est un travail d'équipé avec la police
de windsor la police provinciale de
l'ontario et la police des montagnes du
canada ensemble nous avons pu mener une
opération qui nous a permis de faire
dégager ces manifestants qui sont à
présent évacué de la zone
le blocage du pont ambassador avait
poussé washington à interpeller le
gouvernement de justin trudeau à présent
la route menant au pont et dégager la
circulation peut enfin reprendre la
fermeture du pont a par ailleurs
rapidement entraîner des perturbations
pour l'industrie automobile d'un côté
comme de l'autre de la frontière plus de
25 % des marchandises échangées entre
les deux pays transitent par ce lien
essentiel mais malgré les opérations
policières et les arrestations les
protestataires du convoi compte rester
mobilisé jusqu'au bout on fait ça pour
le futur de nos enfants c'est un combat
pour le canada vous savez un combat pour
le monde le monde nous regarde il faut
mettre fin aux restrictions on devrait
être libre et vivre
après maintenant seize jours de
protestations des convois de la liberté
le gouvernement fédéral s'est dit prêt à
faire tout le nécessaire pour débloquer
ottawa le ministre bill blair a même
évoqué la possibilité d'un déploiement
militaire pour mettre fin à la paralysie
de la ville